once again Donald Trump has been caught
lying about having meetings and instead
went and played golf we've already been
talking about how regularly Trump
criticized President Obama for playing
golf
yet Trump has been playing golf on
average more than once a week since
becoming president of the United States
you'll remember Donald Trump has tweeted
many many times including in November of
2013
President Obama played golf yesterday
many many many tweets from Donald Trump
about Obama's golf playing yet this
weekend Donald Trump took his twelfth
golf trip since his inauguration nine
weeks ago during this game of golf the
press pool had been told that Trump was
very busy in meetings at trump National
Golf Club in Sterling Virginia however
it turns out because of a number of
social media posts that Trump was
playing golf let's start with the first
picture which you can see here this is
an Instagram post of Trump again in his
golfing gear I know you could say well
maybe Trump just likes to wear golfing
gear when he's at a golf course even if
he's only having meetings you see Trump
here outdoors now wearing one of his
golfing outfits and then also Donald
Trump photographed in a golf cart now
okay let me play devil's advocate Pat
isn't it possible that Donald Trump went
to a golf course put on a golfing outfit
got in a golf cart drove out to a
fairway but was just having a business
meeting out there or I'm sorry not
business a political meeting out there
isn't that possible possible but highly
unlikely I would say yeah as usual the
White House hasn't commented on
translatez golf escapade as you know
each of Donald Trump's trips to his own
properties had caught tax payers about
three million dollars we have a tweet
from Donald Trump again talking about
the cost President Barack Obama's
vacation is costing taxpayers millions
of dollars unbelievable this is
supposedly the party of fiscal
responsibility the conversation about
how much golf Trump plays
is analogous to the conversation about
how much taxpayer money is being spent
supporting Donald Trump Golf have it
habit and vacations at properties that
he and his family own and benefit from
at this point in the presidency were at
day 67 to create something like that
President Obama at this point in his
presidency hadn't played a single round
of golf okay
Obama played his 12th round of golf only
on day 201 of his presidency and every
single one was in the DC area no
expensive trips to those rounds of golf
and the thing is the presidency is a
very very tough job so you can play golf
every now and then metal totally fine
yeah but Donald Trump criticized his
predecessor for doing that same thing
and he's doing it a much higher rate and
he's also the guy that said he would
never take vacation well there's four
issues right the problem is not golf per
se the problem is number one Trump made
a huge deal out of Obama playing golf
but it's playing more golf than Obama
number two he said he'd rarely leave the
White House and that he wouldn't take
vacations but he's done it countless
times in the first nine weeks in the
White House number three
White House staff are lying about
Trump's golf okay and number four it's
costing taxpayers tons of money tons and
tons of money much of which is going to
Trump's businesses because that's where
Secret Service and others have to stay I
used to play golf with some frequency
maybe once a week or two during the
summer and I have Trump pegged as the
type of golfer who will hit a ball
straight into the water and then
completely seriously with no irony pull
another ball out of his pocket drop it
and say that was my practice shot hit
the second ball and not take a stroke
penalty which hey you know what keep
score however you want but that's
exactly the type of golfer I see Trump
as we could only hope though that he's a
good golfer because then the games will
be quicker yeah I don't think I get back
to my pretty terrible I've heard that
he's an absolute disastrous golfer so
there it is hey Trump voters are you
worried about this the spending the
lying the being worse than Obama for
something that he flamed Obama for send
me your thoughts if you're willing